Hey Wisecrack, Jared here.
You may have noticed a trend lately.
It seems like every day, some company announces
a new cloud or platform service for people
to download.
A few months ago Google announced its Google
Stadia game streaming platform, which will
include YouTube integration, and allow gamers
to play games from most any screen with an
internet connection.
The announcement was met with some excitement
from big game developers looking for new distribution
deals… and... a lot of skepticism from gamers,
prompting eyerolls and also some questions
like, what games will be available?
Will people actually own their games or will
everything be subscription based?
How will everyone’s data be used?
And what will happen when Google takes on
Sony, Nintendo, Microsoft… and popular PC
gaming platforms like Steam?
It’s not just gaming platforms that have
people asking questions, though.
“Platforms” and “subscription models”
are spreading like the plague.
CBS has successfully forced nerds into submission
by requiring them to pay 5.99 a month for
the privilege of watching Star Trek on their
“All-Access” platform.
Apple recently announced that devices will
be taking a backseat to game, news, and video
subscriptions on a new Apple platform.
And Disney, who already owns… a lot of things
… is launching Disney+, which will ask us
to pay another subscription to watch things
that were once available on Netflix and a
slate of new Marvel shows.
And NBC has yet to launch their own streaming
service which will, again, steal The Office
from Netflix.
People seem annoyed that these services are
just another thing hankering to siphon a few
bucks a month out of their pockets.
But is there a deeper problem here?
And is that problem platforms themselves?
Maybe, maybe not, but for better or worse,
platforms are changing our entire economic
system and I’m here to talk about how, why,
and what it all means.
Welcome to this Wisecrack Edition on the platform
economy.
Today we’re surrounded by platforms.
A Platform is a website or application that
brings two or more sides of a market together,
that is, a digital space where people who
need a service can find and pay for that service.
The earliest example is probably eBay.
The site originally launched as AuctionWeb
in 1995, and created a platform for someone
who wants to sell their autographed Marky
Mark underwear to an eager buyer, this is
real by the way.
After eBay’s success, other companies started
springing up with similar business models--
Amazon originally connected book publishers
with readers --remember when amazon only sold
books?
Ticketmaster created an online space for venues
to sell tickets, and soon there were platforms
for everything… now Uber, connects drivers
with passengers, AirBnB connects spare rooms
with travelers, and Spotify, connects listeners
with music.
But let’s back up for a minute-- how did
we even get here?
Once upon a time before free markets, economies
were regionally based, and self contained.
According to Political Economist Karl Polanyi,
there were three general types of economic
systems:
Reciprocity, where goods are exchanged as
gifts between communities.
For instance, a tribe gifts another tribe
a cow, and eventually gets one back later
on in the year.
Householding, in which families produce food,
goods, and tools for their own use and consumption.
And Redistribution, where a tribal leader
or feudal lord controls all the resources,
and then redistributes them to members of
their society.
Now remember this one, we’re going to come
back to it later.
In all of these, survival wasn’t really
based on how efficient production was.
Sure, a crop may not grow well year over year,
but there were contingency plans such as storing
crops, or minimal exchange on simple markets,
like bartering with your neighbor for what
you need.
But eventually capitalism happened, and the
rules changed.
People became increasingly separated from
the things they needed to survive, turning
to the market to get things like food, water,
and shelter, and selling their skills to whoever
would pay.
By the late 1700s, industry was booming, and
manufacturing began to take over Europe.
In 1776, Scottish economist Adam Smith published
An Inquiry into the Nature and Causes of the
Wealth of Nations, outlining the benefits
of efficient production and singing praises
about how dope the free market is.
And people liked his theories.
The market eventually expanded, as standards
of living began to change, from bare essentials
like food and clothes to luxury items.
But having so many different sellers selling
all these things led to competitive pressures.
If your goods were too expensive, no one would
buy them.
So businesses started lowering production
costs so they could sell their items for less,
while still maintaining enough profits.
Businesses have been lowering production costs
ever since, primarily by turning to technology,
and lowering labor costs.
Which was easy to do if you were in manufacturing
as technology got better and better, and you
could pay less and less for labor.
It started with assembly lines, which provided
companies with cheaper labor that didn’t
need to be trained in any special skills—
instead of learning how to put a whole car
together, a worker just had to learn how to
put one piece of the car in one place.
Eventually, large business realized that robots
could do that instead of people, and since
you don’t have to pay robots salaries, soon
some of these places barely had any employees
at all.
But there were still businesses that couldn’t
really use assembly lines or robots to cut
as many costs— places like grocery stores,
or taxi companies, or movie theaters.
Until the internet came around.
Stores and service providers suddenly had
to compete with… websites, where you could
get the same product or service mailed to
you directly from the distributor with the
click of a button, or find a room in someone’s
house to sleep in instead of booking a hotel
room.
The owners of these new websites, these platforms,
don’t need to pay any labor costs because
people doing the buying and selling are doing
it for them.
In other words, Uber isn’t a taxi company,
it’s a technology company, that pairs an
independently contracted driver with you,
the consumer.
But even those independently contracted drivers
are a liability, as the company moves towards
driverless vehicles.
Okay, so now we understand how platforms happened,
but why are they making people so uneasy?
Well, it might be because people are losing
their sense of autonomy and ownership.
You know how I asked you to remember Karl
Polanyi’s redistribution, where one person
controls and redistributes all the resources?
Like a feudal lord?
Well it’s because more and more, the way
platforms operate feels very similar to that
kind of economy.
Tech companies own assets and distribute them
to us, and as a result, some have argued a
new kind of feudalism has emerged.
One where companies are like lords, and subscribers
are like serfs paying rent to access some
stuff.
So if this is the case, will we all be indentured
to our platforms?
In his 2016 article Evgeny Morozov describes
the steady march of Google and Facebook toward
feudal ownership over greater proportions
of the economy.
By “[destroying] all competition and [making]
the world dependent on their platforms,”
Morozov suggests these neo-feudal lords will
increase their control over how economic resources
are accessed.
Political theorist Nick Srnicek goes as far
as saying that these big companies are becoming
“owners of the infrastructures of society...ending
private property for the masses and having
everything provided as-a-service by quasi-monopolistic
firms.”
We don’t own stuff anymore, companies basically
lease everything to us, and at the moment
these companies are all fighting with each
other over who gets to provide us with access
to stuff that they control.
Instead of owning cars, people are taking
ride shares with changing prices generated
by algorithms.
Instead of owning CDs, we get our music from
Spotify, where it can be taken down.
And it gets even more complicated when these
different platforms start fighting each other
over who has access to what.
Back in January Epic games announced an exclusivity
deal with Metro: Exodus just 2 weeks before
the game’s launch-- after many people had
already pre-ordered it on Steam-- sparking
backlash from Steam users, who wanted their
money back, and Steam itself, who wanted to
sell the game.
If you want to watch The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel
you need an Amazon Prime subscription, if
you want to watch Stranger Things you need
a Netflix subscription, if you want to watch
Star Trek Discovery… well… hopefully you
can borrow a CBS all access password from
your dad.
But the point is people are shelling out money
to all these platforms for temporary access
to a tv show instead of buying a box set.
Remember when you just had to choose between
dvd and blu-ray?
While it’s annoying enough to have 37 different
logins, and frustrating to use up hard drive
space for some dumb software you only need
for one game there are pretty serious ramifications
to these new ownership models.
Last year farmers lost their right to repair
tractors and equipment they bought from John
Deere.
Under a new agreement, farmers can no longer
access or modify the source code of any farm
equipment software, or change engine settings.
They can’t even purchase repair parts without
going through an authorized dealer.
Which you can find through their app.
This is a big deal for farmers, who have been
modifying and fixing their own equipment since
forever.
If an important piece of farm equipment breaks,
they can’t always afford to wait for a John
Deere rep to come update their software for
them.
And not being allowed to upgrade their tractors
means they can’t update their systems to
meet future emissions requirements, which
means when standards change… they’ll have
to buy a new tractor.
This isn’t new, it’s just spreading.
Without software, our smartphones, which have
become pretty indispensable, are just fancy
boxes.
We lease that software.
“Leasing software” isn’t anything new
either, as Microsoft pushes Office 365 subscriptions,
or Adobe doing basically the same thing.
And we’re at a point where we’re literally
advocating for laws so that we can fix things
that we already own.
The ‘right to repair’ movement has already
been picking up steam and appealing to the
US government to address these issues.
So, as big companies like Apple and Google
and Disney take over platforms and buy everyone
out, we might finally have fewer passwords
to memorize and fewer apps to purchase-- but
at what cost?
To put it bluntly: the cost is our data.
According to Srnicek, data “have become
increasingly central to firms and their relations
with workers, customers, and other capitalists.
Platforms became an efficient way to monopolize,
extract, analyze, and use the increasingly
large amounts of data that were being recorded.”
So, while some of these businesses operate
by skimming off the top of sales, or charging
subscription fees, a portion of their money
and success actually comes from collecting,
using, and selling your information.
And these platforms are being increasingly
integrated into our daily lives.
Uber calculates fares based on information
coming in through the app, Spotify recommends
new music based on an analysis of what you’ve
been listening to… and then there are
companies who are flat out selling information
for profit to third party data brokers…
who forward it on to ad agencies, insurance
brokers, and anyone else who wants it.
Kind of like how Rockefeller owned all the
oil, big tech companies monopolizing on data
are starting to take over sections of the
economy, providing valuable services that
people won’t stop paying for…and making
it difficult for anyone else to provide those
services.
What’s different is instead of controlling
physical resources, these businesses control
our information and how its used.
Netflix has so much information on people’s
viewing habits, they can keep recommending
shows for people to watch so they’ll keep
their subscriptions active.
So it goes beyond selling your search history
to advertisers: companies use data to wield
a huge amount of power when it comes to shaping
our consumption, or even the economy as a
whole.
Take Google Stadia.
An article from Brian Feldman in the Intelligencer
points out that linking Stadia so closely
with YouTube might create a feedback loop
of engagement metrics that could ultimately
influence game-design choices.
According to Feldman, “it’s not hard to
imagine a world in which the Stadia platform
ends up wielding major, indirect influence
over what types of things game developers
create and what YouTubers decide to stream.”
With everyone chasing trends, some game developers
might just end up creating cookie-cutter games
that all look the same.
We see it with videos, like how when one watched
conspiracy theory videos, YouTube suggested
more conspiracy videos, leading to an increase
in more conspiracy content, leading to more
conspiracy theorists, who wanted more conspiracy
content.
They’ve since fixed that, but you’re usually
only one Mukbang video away from the topic
dominating your homepage.
But are we getting ahead of ourselves?
More than a century ago, policymakers were
confronted with a very similar problem, when
people started using telephones.
People owned their telephones, but they didn’t
own the system they were using to communicate.
As people began to rely on telephones for
communication, phone companies turned into
big unregulated monopolies.
So, the government started placing restrictions
on the companies to keep them from exploiting
consumers, allowing them to be monopolies,
but treating them as utilities.
So maybe the federal trade commission will
do something similar with tech platforms…
some policymakers even propose creating new
departments in government to oversee big platforms.
While it’s still unclear what that will
look like, with Uber drivers striking to unionize
and Mark Zuckerberg testifying before congress,
it seems like calls for intervention will
only increase
So what do you think?
Are we destined for lives in the Matrix where
our data is extracted so big companies can
profit trillions of dollars and dictate everything
we do with our time?
Or will we find a middle ground where we live
harmoniously with our platforms in some kind
of data-driven utopia?
Let us know what you think.
Thanks to all our patrons who support the
channel and our podcasts.
Don’t forget to hit that subscribe button